[Music]
on camera she laughed
while she badgered her staff and so all
good things must end
and also the ellen degeneres show yes
the 83 year old entertainer just
announced that the upcoming 19th season
of her show will be its last
apparently she created a workplace more
toxic than an amazon warehouse in
chernobyl
countless allegations surfaced last
summer that the show's work environment
was
rife with harassment and discrimination
following those charges ellen's
ratings dropped faster than kevin
spacey's pants at a boy band pool party
try to say that fast but ellen told the
today show
home of matt lauer got the bad
bad press actually had nothing to do
with her decision
right and the titanic didn't hit an
iceberg it chose to sink
if it was why i was quitting i would
have not come back this year
i really did think about not coming back
because it did
um you know i mean it was devastating
i am a kind person i am a
person who likes to make people happy
no the real reason she says it was just
too easy
telling the hollywood reporter quote
when you're a creative person you
constantly need to be challenged
and as great as this show is and as fun
as it is it's just not a challenge
anymore
well that's true here's an idea when
your viewership is down to 43
why not consider that the challenge
in the meantime to make sure that my
staff isn't pissed at me like ellen i
had my assistant james
ask them how stuff is going so far
so how's greg that behind the scenes
lately oh unbelievable when i first got
this job
greg flew to arkansas and packed my bags
for me
and then when we got to new york he said
i could live at his apartment
and he would go stay at a youth hostel
which doesn't really make sense but oh
yeah
the show's been great well my wedding
dress got destroyed right before the
wedding so greg stayed up for
36 hours hand knitting me a new one
and he brought it to my apartment
delivered it to me and before he left
he gave my husband a pedicure my husband
even asked greg just went
straight for his toes then he was also
the dj
he cleaned up and we woke up the morning
after the wedding greg was in our
kitchen
asking us how we liked our eggs i don't
know how he got him
pretty good i guess although it was
weird the other day he came in with this
igloo cooler
and he said oh here's one of my kidneys
i was like greg i'm not even sick and he
said oh well don't worry just in case
you are later you should have this
there's a pretty exhausting
investigation into my staff
there cat uh i think we could safely say
that i am not a jerk
despite the rumors do you think this is
just people
you when you become successful you have
to spend less time
with people around you because you're
servicing for that take ellen
degeneres she's servicing millions of
people in her show
therefore she has to kind of like
mitigate or control the amount of
exposure with actual real people
does that make sense it does in theory
uh but when you
but with with i'm still always hanging
out on the street and i'm super famous
um no but all these reports
there were so many of them of people
being like multiple people had the same
story of
her handlers before you an interview or
anything with her would come up and say
don't look her in the eye
but that's an old story for they they
use that with
all celebrities like sinatra somebody
goes in the elevator don't look them in
the eye
i always feel that that's like the go-to
due to it's also weird that she won't
acknowledge it at all she's like this
had nothing to do
just be like oh my ratings are down i'm
leaving she's like no it's just not
challenging and i'm so creative and i'm
actually so good at my job
that i have to quit no like new you know
challenging
new challenges she should look at let
people look at her
okay that could be the new challenge
dana uh ellen is blaming this on
misogyny
but there was a lot there were more
there were females that were involved
in in criticizing her and her staff yeah
that was not um that yeah was gender
you were called gender neutral yeah so
um when she's doing the interview with
savannah
to me like she's she has no there's no
joy in her voice right so she's saying
that she's ending it on her own terms
because she doesn't feel challenged
enough but she actually sounds
like she like there's a gun to her head
yeah so instead she's like
well she's speaking as if like she knows
that she has to do this interview and
get through it
but if she really wanted us to believe
that she could be there wasn't challenge
anymore i loved it for 19 years i got a
lot of
projects coming up and i'm sorry that
people felt that way around my team
but we're moving forward i mean there's
there's a way to do that i mean i have
to be everybody's press secretary she's
good yeah she's really good speaking of
gun to head how do you think greg got
all those testimonials from his staff
that was all at gunpoint obviously the
man is a tyrant you have an amazing
staff
i have a source in hollywood his name is
jesse waters
[Laughter]
he said on the following today that
ellen has a staff of
255 people yeah that came from tyrus
actually is that true
jesse's source was tyrus oh my god
so now we're playing the telephone game
yes cat
guy 255. it's a lot of i like helen
i've always liked her on this on the
seinfeld thing when
they were driving around the car in l.a
and the car getting comedians having
coffee yeah yeah
uh communist cars comedians and cars she
was great i was telling dana earlier
today she was
approachable shy i would say but
approachable i've always liked her
she's quite vulnerable greg i can't
stand them she lets me
come over and just look at her for a few
hours
then i'll reconsider having a successful
show for
19 years or seasons in that day part is
really hard like there's talent there
there are people working hard
i think part of the issue is when your
whole
brand is just joy happiness and love yes
and then this kind of explodes all over
it that
is your problem ended every show being
be kind to one another
exactly right that becomes this is why
like i said jerry springer i'm
always angry and mean because that's who
you are that's who i
am so it's all like oh i'm gonna say
everybody hug everybody then i go
outside i just yell
it we expect abuse
[Laughter]
you know the other thing though is i
want her to be a guest on this show so i
have to defend her and i'm going to say
that there's a lot a lot of people
complain about people just because you
complain about
your boss right it's just like it's a
thing it's a natural thing to do
even when it's being recorded by me i've
never
don't know what you're talking about